recently satellite cameras exposed a
well hidden secret in the rain forests
of Africa distinct clearings buried deep
within the forest these strange islands
are located in a northwest corner of the
Republic of Congo where an expanse of
lush vegetation makes up odds Allah
National Park the Westerners were
unaware of these clearings local people
call them bys in the dim morning light
creatures cautiously approached the by
it's a group of western lowland gorillas
a large male sports a waistcoat of white
hair a symbol of his dominance at more
than 300 pounds this silverback rules a
harem of unrelated females and family
members on any given day several groups
may share the bye in peace but the
equilibrium is fragile here and easily
upset this morning a young solitary male
is also on the scene he Swagger's in
perhaps for a drink and a bite to eat
but to him the bye is also an attractive
singles bar a place where he can I the
market of potential mates
the young females give him the once-over
and he conducts himself with style
casually moving to an even better
vantage point a dominant silverback has
enormous responsibilities looking out
for the welfare of his group his family
relies on him for guidance for
leadership for protection any challenge
to a Silverbacks Authority is a
potential threat to the stability of his
family this one tries to ignore the
intruder in their midst but how long can
he hold out with a rush of confidence
the single male dances across the by
creating a spectacle
you
the silverback has seen enough they
silently but aggressively face-off
far out matched the young male turns
tail and runs calm restored the by
returns to its more peaceful state